oh boy that's a lot of carrots hey
everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by biltbar
and we're gonna be taking a look at
lizzo's vegan dive but first let me tell
you about my sponsor billbar so if you
guys are a snack queen or king like me
yes queen
you need these bars in your life i have
like a whole pantry of snacks in my
house but i keep these right here in my
office and like everywhere else in the
house for any time that like a snack
attack hit and you guys know what i say
about zero guilt foods i mean unless you
stole it from a baby all foods are zero
guilt so today's flavor hit me up
you know what
color coded
color coated snacks yes purple purple
all right we are gonna do the cherry
garcia oh
cherry barcia
oh my goodness that is hilarious all
right so
17 grams of protein
nothing like the combo of chocolate and
cherry let's see how it holds up
[Music]
that is barlicious terrible terrible
abby cherry garcia is a lot better
but i love this because they're made
with real chocolate so they actually
taste like a chocolate bar and not like
a chalky protein bar but they're packed
with all that protein that we love now
they are low in sugar so when i need
like a complete snack for post workout i
always like to pair them with some fruit
or toast or oats so if you want to try
these out yourself check out the link in
my description and use my promo code
abbysharp15 to get 15 off of your order
but before we get into it feel free to
pause the screen or look at the
description to check out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating so as always feel
free to skip this video if it's not
supportive to your journey and if you
are new here welcome please don't forget
to subscribe to the channel and ring
that little bell so that you never miss
out on an episode since lizzo doesn't
have a youtube channel we are going over
to tick tock to take a look at a typical
day of eats and while you're there folks
definitely follow me at abby's kitchen
for lots of great myth busting and judge
nutrition tips let's take a look what
she's eating so i started off the day
with some kanji
and these little delicious patties and i
ate them together with a little bit of
just egg on top with all the fixings i
think that's lentil inside of that okay
so
congee is like a rice porridge typically
eaten on its own or with meat or fish
but because lizzo of course is vegan she
tops hers off with some egg replacement
and then two lentil patties on the side
so here we're getting some carbs from
the rice and the congee and in the
patties as well as some protein and some
fat from the vegan egg and also in the
lentil filling now i also took a little
peek at the nutrition info on the egg
replacement that she was using uh just
to see how it compares to regular eggs
and i was actually surprised to learn
that they are even just a little bit
higher in protein but they are also
higher in fat sodium calories and lack
the vitamins a d e fully and zinc found
in traditional eggs so i am all for
vegan alternatives for folks who can't
or don't want to eat the og but do note
that vegan doesn't necessarily always
mean healthier or nutritionally
equivalent feelings and then of course
what about some of the venture capitals
okay so that was super quick and it's a
little hard to see exactly what's in the
salad but it looks like there might be
some kind of vegan chicken or tofu in
there of some sort of protein maybe some
corn for carbs i don't know it's really
hard to tell but if we're going with the
south western salad theme i would do
like beans for protein rice and corn for
carbs avocado and some dressing for some
fat and loads of colorful veggies for
nutrients and fiber
and then for dinner i have these
delicious rice cakes that i made with
this mushroom carrot sauce and vegan
mozzarella cheese i toe it up [ __ ] it
was so delicious and that chocolate you
saw earlier i ate in between my lunch
and my dinner oh my god that looks so
good for the cold weather we are
currently having sledding just enjoying
it one thing oops so these are not your
die debbie's rice cakes what lizzo's
describing is actually made from pounded
rice which is formed into a cylinder
like shape and it creates almost like a
thick pasta noodle with more of like a
sticky and chewy texture and then lizzo
pairs hers with a mushroom carrot sauce
for some fiber and veggie action and
then tops it off with some vegan
mozzarella now while the nutritional
profile of vegan mozzarella will vary
depending on the brand most often
they're fairly low in protein usually
anywhere between zero to three grams and
then we can compare that to traditional
parts skin mozzarella which has closer
to seven grams of protein neither are
huge sources of protein so i would
personally try to throw in like a can of
lentils or beans or a veggie ground down
in there and then dump a ton of
nutritional yeast on top the vegan
community is obsessed with nooch aka
nutritional yeast and i would say for
pretty good reason i mean just two
tablespoons contains eight grams of
protein and three grams of fiber plus a
whack load of b vitamins including b12
in the fortified versions so i say i put
that on everything
also i am all for a little chocolate
midday pick-me-up so
good choice lisso of course i had hella
water like four of those okay let's talk
about this do you really need to be
drinking four liters of water a day
i mean fluid needs are highly
individualized and based on a variety of
factors but generally speaking most
experts recommend that women consume on
average about 2.7 liters of water per
day which is already over 11 cups that
can sound a little overwhelming for a
lot of us but you don't actually have to
drink it in pure up h2o if that's too
taxing for you so soup sparkling water
juice tea and yes even coffee all count
towards your daily tally now i would
expect that on rehearsal or performance
days lizzo might genuinely be quite
thirsty so if 4 liters feels good to her
body then great i say drink up but if
you're unsure of your own unique needs
check out the color of your urine to
gauge your state of hydration if you're
not thirsty and your urine is like a
pale yellow drinking more water may just
unnecessarily be increasing your trips
to the bathroom now all that said what
are my overall thoughts on lizzo's diet
now because we're reviewing a super
quickie tick tock and not a lengthy
youtube video we don't have a very clear
idea of specific portions and
ingredients which does make it
challenging to accurately estimate
calories and macros but
my best guess based on rough
calculations is that she's consuming
about 1400 calories on this day now we
have no sense of her activity level how
her meals were made or if there was
anything else eaten off camera but
assuming that this is an accurate
estimate 400 calories is probably quite
low for her needs especially on
rehearsal or performance days when the
girl is on full-on beast mode on stage
now it's also worth quickly noting that
it's normal for calorie intake to
fluctuate day to day a bit so i don't
want to insinuate that lizzo is
intentionally restricting here from what
i've seen from some of her other eat
with me style videos lisso's meals are
quite balanced culturally diverse varied
and nutrient rich she'll also often eat
a lot of kind of vegan comfort foods
like vegan burgers or hot dogs burritos
and tacos or try new fun tik tok trends
like emily morico's infamous salmon bowl
ricotta toast as well as some
questionable trends like putting mustard
on watermelon and nature's cereal aka
fruit salad but yeah
i'm glad that one's on the out would you
please leave without a fuss right now
okay
now as we've seen on this particular
what in a day liza will often lean on
vegan meat alternatives like egg
replacement and vegan mozzarella which i
think are such great stand-ins for a lot
of my ethical plant-based folks i am so
grateful that in 2021 we've got so many
amazing options for folks with dietary
restrictions to help keep them out of
scarcity mentality but then on the flip
side i do see a lot of people not lizzo
by the way but a lot of people present
these faux products as health foods
while demonizing the og now healthy is a
very loaded subjective term so for some
folks these actually may be much
healthier but that doesn't mean they are
necessarily nutritionally superior often
they're higher in sodium oils additives
calories and lower in micronutrients so
i say
yes these can make amazing stand-ins for
recreating your favorite omnivore meals
but i would make these kind of accents
in your diet while leaning a little more
heavily on less processed whole foods
like tofu beans lentils nuts and seeds
now speaking of nutrients while it is
difficult to gauge lizzo's total
nutrient intake from a single tic talk
video this date did appear low in
calcium zinc vitamin b12 omega-3 vitamin
d and iron now these nutrients are more
challenging to get on a vegan diet on a
good day but it becomes even more of a
challenge when total calories are so low
so this is a great opportunity to focus
on adding nutrition to the day so
throwing in that can of lentils and
nutritional yeast at dinner and maybe
adding some snacks like walnuts or a
smoothie made out of fortified soy milk
in her day and i also of course would
consider a vegan supplement if she
doesn't take one already and if she's
having a hard time getting in extra food
due to like a reserved appetite i would
definitely pull back on the water water
is great i'm not saying it's not but if
we're chronically having a hard time
meeting our nutrient needs we would want
to maximize the nutrition in our fluids
now lastly i just want to briefly chat
about food and diet culture messaging
that i've picked up on from lizzo's tick
tock starting of course with the good so
i had pizza for dinner last night so i
woke up this morning and was like you
know what i'm gonna have pizza for
breakfast but when i got to my kitchen i
was like um i don't think i want pizza
for breakfast anymore but then i started
fighting i was like no you deserve to
pamper yourself pizza is like this
comfort food like go for it but my body
was like nah so i asked myself what did
i really want i made a big-ass hash
now i don't think i should be rewarded
for eating good as much as i don't think
i should be
shamed for eating bad i think we
eliminate the words good and bad with
eating altogether but i had pizza for
lunch though
yes girl yes what i'm hearing here is
lizzo exercising food neutrality and
some self-compassion when we dichotomize
foods as good and bad we project those
moral qualifiers on ourselves so when we
allow ourselves something bad and we
feel guilt or shame around it it's hard
to just like enjoy the pizza or to hear
our body telling us when we might not
actually want any more pizza so what i
often see is that we get into this like
last supper mentality and we insist on
eating all the bad food until it's like
out of place out of mind and we can
start fresh being good again but like i
always say foods may not be
nutritionally equal but if we make them
morally equal we can start to intimately
understand our true needs and it seems
like in this case lizzo's body didn't
want or need more pizza it wanted a
colorful nutrient-dense well-balanced
vegan scramble i also like that lizzo
uses her tik tok as like a safe space to
enjoy food and will even do the eat with
me style videos to help normalize some
of her followers fear foods now as for
some of the more problematic content on
her tick tock i mean to be honest they
are pretty few and far in between as i
find her tick tock to be a pretty safe
and food neutral space that really
celebrates the joy of eating and i think
that's why that controversial cleanse
tick tock that i discussed in my video
right here was particularly so jarring
for people to watch so definitely check
out my thoughts on that video here if
you haven't already but i do want to
quickly comment on her morning green
juice and also her carrot feast let's
take a look
so this i
i just do not get like lizzo's face
tells it all she looks a little bit like
my baby the first time he tasted a lemon
big bite
probably not the most joyous food
experience i just say what's the point
like sure green juice is nutrient dense
but it does seem at odds with the rest
of her food philosophy to need to get it
over with by like choking it down every
day when they said let food be thy
medicine they didn't mean for it to
taste like
medicine there are so many more
enjoyable and arguably more nutritious
ways to get in your vegetables when we
actually get the whole fiber intact and
since lizzo is vegan and already eats a
fair bit of vegetables i would say that
this torture ritual is somewhat obsolete
i would way rather see her focus her
energy on adding foods to her diet that
are rich in iron calcium omega-3s etc as
we spoke about earlier rather than
dragging herself through a glass of
bitter greens and speaking of evidence
her green juice is unnecessary let's
talk about her carrot feast carrot is
the new it girl for the summer i had a
bunch of carrots so i made carrot juice
chopped some carrots up and made that
carrot dip that i love so much from tik
tok put some onions and garlic cinnamon
spices
some spinach put in the blender then i
took some more carrots skinned them
marinated them boiled them in a
delicious like hot doggy type sauce had
a char on them put them on a bun i had
an amazing carrot feast
carrot juice carrot dog
and then this delicious
carrot dip that i saw on tik tok
um
don't knock it till you tried it okay so
here we have carrots three ways we've
got a juice a carrot hot dog and a
carrot dip and they all look delicious
and i can totally see something like
this appearing on like a michelin star
venue so i do applaud lizzo for her
creativity here and as a one-off novelty
meal i also think it's kind of fun and
also resourceful if you do have a ton of
carrots in your house but as a very
broad general nutrition tip for those
watching we do want to make sure that
we're enjoying a variety of ingredients
so as not to displace other important
macro and micronutrients in our day
especially if we want to avoid looking
like a pumpkin or a carrot ourselves
from keratinemia aka the orange
pigmentation of the skin that one gets
from eating too many orange veg now i
promise it's totally benign and very
common in folks with vegetarian diets or
vegan diets or those who are genetically
predisposed so i myself have dealt with
this my entire life but ideally we want
to spread out the produce love a single
glass of carrot juice already supplies
over 200 of your beta carotene for the
day so we get a lot more nutritional
bang for our buck by maybe pairing the
carrot juice with like a veggie dog and
like a bean based dip something with a
little bit of protein and fat in the mix
with all that said is lizzo's tick tock
a safe and food neutral space for the
most part i would say yes obviously like
every other human on tick tock lizzo
isn't immune to the pressures of diet
culture and occasionally participates in
problematic trends and while the world
can be really mad at her for this i
think we also need to be empathetic and
stop trying to forcefully typecast her
as some bopo bipoc queen just because
she's in a larger body an important part
of this body positivity movement is
autonomy and choice and i think lizzo
deserves the right to choose what to do
with her body without judgment or shame
just as much as any thin white
influencer pushing green juice and lemon
water there is an obvious double
standard would i love her to not imply
that we need to choke down green juice
to be healthy yes don't like that would
i love for her to not tote the benefits
of a bogus smoothie cleanse also yes i
talked about that a lot in my video
right here but i also think lizzo is on
her own journey and she does seem to
present a relatively neutral non-extreme
normal experience that i think a lot of
people can relate to one that's largely
grounded in balance and an unapologetic
joy for food but that also occasionally
dabbles and experiments with
pseudoscience woo she's not a perfect
bopo poster child and she's not a diet
culture diva either like most of us
she's just trying to figure out what
works for her and on that note that's
all that i have for you guys today thank
you again to buildbar for sponsoring
this video if you liked it be sure to
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below on who you'd like to see me review
next subscribe to the channel and i'll
see you next time on abby's kitchen bye